[Música]
este 20 de junio es el Día Mundial del
refugiado acnuro promueve la
conmemoración en todo el mundo para
movilizar las iniciativas de protección
y las buenas prácticas que promuevan la
integración de los solicitantes de asilo
en el mundo hay al menos 110 millones de
personas en condición de refugiadas o
desplazadas y las cifras siguen en
aumento sin un cambio de enfoque en la
materia que permita dignificar a quienes
dejan su hogar forzosamente hoy queremos
en France 24 reflexionar alrededor de
esta crisis instalada hace décadas y
sobre quienes trabajan el contraviento y
marea y contra los gobiernos para
rescatar a miles nos acompaña desde
Barcelona Laura lanuza Ella es la
directora de comunicación de Open Arms
Laura gracias por estar en directo
América bienvenida
Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias
mire el enfoque con el que los gobiernos
combaten los desplazamientos forzados es
principalmente y pese a las constantes
iniciativas que se anuncian la
criminalización cuál sería para usted
una narrativa más efectiva para tratar
una crisis que es creciente y constante
bueno Tendremos que partir del hecho de
que la migración es un hecho que ha
acompañado al ser humano desde el
principio de los tiempos y que la
migración es enriquecedora y es algo
natural para el ser humano
deberíamos trabajar comenzar a trabajar
sobre sobre la empatía y sobre la
dignidad de las personas partiendo del
hecho de que tanto tenemos una
declaración universal de los Derechos
Humanos que dice que migrar es un
derecho absolutamente para todas las
personas de este planeta con lo cual no
deberían tener más derechos uno que otro
sino que simplemente migrar es un es un
hecho natural evidentemente
las migraciones forzosas vienen vienen
dadas por situaciones de persecución de
conflictos de guerras en los países de
origen y es ahí donde el mundo donde
estos países que han suscrito estos
estos convenios internacionales y
esta declaración de Derechos Humanos
deberían promover las vías legales y
seguras para que nadie tuviera que
perder la vida o que jugarse en la vida
en el trayecto para llegar a un lugar
seguro ahora hay una falta de política
humanitaria pero también aportarían
enormemente políticas climáticas
inversiones En la paz y en la economía
de los países del sur global por ejemplo
este Éxodo forzado al final le cree
usted termina siendo la suma de muchos
males
efectivamente No hay ninguna persona que
deje su hogar que deje su familia que
deje sus amigos lo abandone todo y se
ponga en marcha si no es porque en el
lugar de origen la situación es muy
complicada evidentemente Tenemos que
trabajar sobre sobre el origen deben ser
los países en los que en los que se debe
trabajar se deben empoderar las
comunidades de los países del del inicio
de estas rutas migratorias y no
solamente eso occidente debe dejar de
intervenir en sus gobiernos tenemos
sabemos que el tráfico de armas el
comercio de armas es uno de los motores
que al final acaba interviniendo los
países acaban generando estas guerras
que no son sino
uno de los Hechos de los hechos más
importantes que provocan estos estos
sexos migratorios
nos tenemos que focalizar en eso y no
solamente eso sino que hay que preservar
la dignidad de las personas y para ello
no puede ser que las personas se tengan
que poner en manos de mafias para huir
de ese lugar de origen para llegar a un
lugar seguro se Debería Debería haber
unos días legales y seguras por las
cuales estas personas pudieran llegar al
punto final del trayecto para poder
solicitar este Refugio bueno esta fecha
nos llega mientras Europa está
gestionando el último naufragio en
Grecia que es además el más grande que
se ha visto hasta el momento este año
una embarcación con 750 migrantes que
fue avistada por otros barcos mientras
estaba mientras estaba en mar abierto
incluidos los guardacostas Pero esto no
evitó una tragedia que en este momento
avergüenza a la Unión Europea y puso a
Grecia a investigar yo le quiero
preguntar es entendible o es
justificable ese rechazo preexistente a
Los viajeros que llegan a los lugares en
condición irregular Aunque bien sabemos
que falta mucho por aclarar sobre las
condiciones en las que fue avistado este
barco si existe un claro tono de rechazo
a seguir ayudando o a permitir que
lleguen a tierra
está claro lo que está haciendo la Unión
Europea en los últimos años es una
política es una necropolítica lo que
está haciendo es externalizar fronteras
a terceros países para que hagan el
trabajo sucio para que estas personas
sean retenidas en esos países para que
no lleguen a Europa en lugar de preparar
de tener políticas en las cuales se
pudieran acoger a estas personas en
Europa y no solamente hay una
criminalización sobre las personas que
migran sino que hay una criminalización
sobre las ongs que estamos trabajando en
el terreno en este caso en el mar
Mediterráneo porque al final los otros
salvamos vidas y hacemos algo que es tan
básico y tan fundamental y tan
primordial como proteger la vida en el
mar sino que lo que hacemos también es
denunciar el hecho de que las
administraciones los gobiernos lo que
están haciendo es dejar morir a estas
personas el caso más claro y más
reciente desgraciadamente de estas
necropolíticas no de esta de esta
externa fronteras de esta
criminalización de estas personas es el
caso del del naufragio de la semana
pasada muchas horas antes del naufragio
todas las autoridades de la zona estaban
alertadas de que había una embarcación
en peligro no solamente eso sino que
había imágenes de esa embarcación se
sabía y todo el mundo era consciente de
que eso estaba sucediendo de que eran
más de 700 personas en peligro en lugar
de activar todas los todos los servicios
de guardacostas que tienen las
administraciones tanto de Grecia de
Italia y de Malta lo que se hizo fue una
inacción deliberada en este caso se está
investigando pero cada vez es más claro
de que los guardacostas griegos los que
estaban haciendo era remolcar esta Barca
para para que saliera de su zona de
responsabilidad es más
con lo cual estamos realmente hasta ante
un caso muy muy grave de deshumanización
de todas estas personas
la estrategia de criminalización hacia
las ongs que estamos que no hacemos otra
labor más que proteger la vida en el mar
en lo que nos están nos están haciendo
con decretos y con leyes de los
diferentes países es alejarnos de la
zona para que no veamos y podamos
denunciar Pero eso no solamente
tiene como resultado el desgaste de las
ongs que estamos allá que estamos allá
con la sociedad civil que nos apoya sino
que lo que están haciendo y el resultado
inmediato es el aumento de las muertes
en el mar solamente este año más de
1.200 personas han muerto han perdido la
vida intentando llegar a Europa
evidentemente después de este naufragio
serán muchísimas más pues mire Laura ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo lamentablemente
no tengo tiempo para hacerle más
preguntas pero sí llama mucho la
atención como también lo que se
evidencia es que los gobiernos se quitan
algo de responsabilidad que terminan
asumiendo organizaciones como Open Arms
en la búsqueda de migrantes y aún así
pues son criminalizadas así que le
agradezco mucho por entregarnos no
solamente el panorama sino ayudarnos a
vivenciar un poco más lo que es ser un
migrante y abandonarlo todo para tratar
de buscar otra opción de supervivencia
es la hora lanúsa directora de
comunicaciones de Open Arms que tenga un
feliz día
Gracias igualmente muchas gracias a
nuestros televidentes quédense con
nosotros segundos de pausa y ya volvemos
con más de directo América
[Música]